today it's time to figure out how
kubernetes actually
runs containers on notes let's check it
out
with a whole universe of things to learn
it's important to start with the
essentials
let's go over the concepts that make
kubernetes usable scalable and just
downright awesome
are you ready so with all of our
conversation about how
pods run our containers i figured it
would make sense to talk about
nodes which means it's time to figure
out what are nodes
that's an important topic the simple way
of looking at it is that a node is a
virtual or physical machine
that you run your workloads on wow
that's pretty straightforward
and i know that in kubernetes we operate
on clusters which are you know groups of
one or more worker nodes
but in order to get the automation that
kubernetes provides
i'm sure nodes are more than just any
old virtual or physical machine right
exactly each node actually contains the
services necessary to run
pods a container runtime for running
containers
a cubelet for making sure that
everything that should be running
is and the cube proxy for handling
networking
aha so that's how kubernetes keeps track
of pods
that also explains how pods get ipm
points and other necessary features for
running at scale
like you know being able to attach to a
running pod for debugging
yep now if we had to manually manage all
of the pods on each node
it would be impossible to handle that's
one of the most
important reasons kubernetes exists the
way kubernetes actually manages these
pods is through what's called
the control plane the control plane is
responsible for handling
all of these details by exposing an api
this is where kubernetes can define
deploy and manage
the life cycle of our pods right there's
a lot going on in the control plane
let's look at some of the components
that make up the control plane and what
they do
first there's the api server itself
which handles data validation and
configuration for all of the api objects
next there's fcd which is a key value
store for holding onto all the important
data that kubernetes uses
plus there's the scheduler here's where
the important decisions get made about
where exactly a pod will run the
scheduler can look at the available
resources for all the nodes and make
sure that a pod goes to a node that can
handle it
and don't forget about the controller
manager where the core kubernetes logic
happens
one of the big responsibilities here is
lifecycle management
to make sure all the various pieces are
working correctly
similarly there's the cloud controller
manager
which lets kubernetes hook into cloud
providers so if you're running google
kubernetes engine
the cloud controller manager is what
speaks to google cloud when something is
needed
like a new virtual machine for a node
having that abstraction from dealing
with the individual details of each
cloud provider
sure sounds nice wow the control plane
is responsible for a lot
but with all of that how do you actually
declare the details to kubernetes
that's where the kubernetes api comes in
let's try it out in the next episode
so that's how kubernetes does all the
things that it does
if you're going to deploy a container
you'd make a pod that uses your
container you'd make sure kubernetes has
nodes
and then it figures out the rest that's
right
the cubelets on the nodes are watching
what's going on on the node itself so
when the control plane needs to schedule
a pod on that node
both the control plane and the node
itself have enough information to make
sure it works
plus if a pod runs into an issue the
control plane will work with the cubelet
to remove the unhealthy pod and replace
it with a new one
wow that was a lot of great info on
nodes
but now it's time to take a deeper dive
into the kubernetes api
alright stay tuned everybody if you want
to get hands on
check out the link in the description
and if you enjoyed the episode
subscribe for more
you